depuis que david levy a retrouvé sa mère
le mois dernier il ne peut plus parler
d'elle je passe au moins de trois heures
facetime avec ma mère chaque jour avant
d'aller dormir et on se dit bonnut les
yeux dans les yeux
david est né le 4 avril 1975 à l'hôpital
juif de montréal
il a été donné en adoption quatre jours
plus tard à une famille juive marocaine
je suis né blanc et bleu mais il vient
de découvrir qu'il n'est ni juif ni
marocain m'a merci lui simoni née
lefebvre et mon père c'est un mot ni
catholique
côté irlandais mon père est coté que
fait ma mère david de son vrai nom
jonathan money elle fouille d'un amour
de jeunesse
sa mère avait 16 ans lorsqu'elle a
accouché son père est alors parti
travailler dans l'ouest du pays
ses parents se sont retrouvés quelques
années plus tard pour se marier
c'est grâce à un cousin qui l'a
retrouvée par le biais d'un de ces
stries cette compagnie qui analyse votre
adn qu'il a pu remonter la filière vers
ses parents biologiques
début novembre il prend son courage à
deux mains et les appels j'ai appelé je
reçois la boîte vocale
je laisse un message et on me rappelle
du même numéro je réponds et c'est mon
père qui dit des veines du tome i need
is and judy d'agde et c'est là où la
fontaine éclate
le lendemain il part à leur rencontre
le premier à m'accueillir c'est mon père
dehors la maison ils m'attendaient une
accolade vraiment
c'est je peux pas le décrire c'est mon
coeur qui bat et on dirait que ça
sortait de de la cage thoracique et bien
sûr ma mère j'ai couru dans ses bras
pendant 25 ans j'ai pas pu sortir le mot
maman de ma bouche quand j'étais dans
les bras de ma mère ou dans les bras de
mon père c'est je t'aime under
aujourd'hui à tirer comme des aimants
ils ne se lâchent plus
à chaque jour de ma vie j'ai rêvé que
pour crier à ma porte vous le trouvez
comment votre fils 43 ans plus tard vous
avez un adulte devant vous on sait mon
but est t'es mon petit bébé soit son
docteur est dit on vient de donner un
nouveau nom et ça c'est maintenant il
faut vivre les premières expériences
parce que je pensais que j'étais folle
j'ai dit je les besoins et j'ai besoin
la star
j'ai besoin de toucher à qui il
ressemble
il ressemble à mon frère pour moi c'est
au jeu joue sur le terrain et j'ai perdu
mon frère quand j'avais quelqu'un qui
aimait 33 il rentre le média 15,3 tout
ce rattrapage à faire tous ces visages
et ces noms à retenir ses meilleurs
oui je te dois venir danser grand-mère
oui je passais deux fils il dit qu'à
grand frère je passais s'enlever sa
nièce des nouvelles des neiges du jour
l'homme
le vide que tous les trois ressentait
depuis des années est maintenant comblé
le fait qu'ils soient là maintenant
physiquement ça fait quoi
il incarne un compte où la boucle vers
la nouvelle
bobo qu'on avait alors conseillé à tous
les maux comme son plein le cers ironie
bravo à nos fils ouais j'avais toujours
un fils ce sera noël dans quelques jours
à noël qui s'annonce très spécial dans
la famille mouny vous rendez compte du
cadeau de noël que vous avez annoncé le
gâteau c'est un macbook donato jeune âge
les 10 le jour je suis l'homme le plus
chanceux au monde et rien pour moi est
pris à personne depuis changé
[Musique]